doctor who isn't just the longest
running sci-fi series of all time it's
also one of the most iconic but just
what makes the doctor tick from monsters
to madmen to Moffat fan theories here's
the untold truth of Doctor Who one
reason doctor who has managed to last so
long as the fact that it's not beholden
to one particular star early on in the
show's history the producers built in a
process to change the main actor and
have it fit right in with the narrative
regeneration by regenerating the doctor
can change to a new actor with a
different personality though he
typically retains most of his or her
memories this whole idea came about
because by 1966 58 year old star William
Hartnell was ready to leave Doctor Who
not only was his health on the downturn
but he didn't care for how the show
style was evolving under the guidance of
newly appointed producer in his Lloyd
and story editor Jerry Davis but how to
continue Doctor Who if the lead actor
walked out by killing him off kinda the
show's creative staff came up with an
idea whenever this centuries-old doctor
grew exhausted and weak he could
regenerate and take on a new form in a
new body provided by a new actor of
course that ability to freely recast its
main character has helped the show stay
alive for decades this concept gives
enough wiggle room to recast the role as
needed and though it's certainly a risky
move on the surface it's been a key part
of the show's longevity so how'd they
come up with the idea well by tripping
on acid of course according to an
internal memo from the show's original
creative team regeneration was supposed
to be a horrifying experience where the
doctor relives some of the most
unendurable moments of his long life the
doctor is forced to face everything he's
done in the moment of regeneration the
producers say it's as if he's had the
LSD drugged and instead of experiencing
the kicks he has the he'll and dank
horror which can be its effect since
1963 the appearance of the doctor has
changed repeatedly and the show itself
has evolved in a number
occassions arguably the only true
constant in doctor who is the TARDIS
short for time and relative dimension in
space the doctor uses the bigger on the
inside spaceship to whisk companions
around space and time it looks like a
blue police call box because has a
time-traveling alien the doctor needs to
be able to blend in while on earth
originally the show's writers intended
for the TARDIS to have a different form
each adventure landing into whatever
landscape or setting the doctor found
himself in unfortunately the show's
meager budget preclude the crew from
changing the TARDIS every week and since
they already had the blue police box
they stuck with that naturally this
problem came with its own in universe
solution in the show itself the TARDIS
is outfitted with a camouflaging
chameleon circuit one that happens to be
perpetually broken the show has also
hinted on a number of occasions that the
doctor could get fixed if he wanted to
but that he's actually kind of fond of
the whole blue box look in 1963 Verity
Lambert was hired as the first producer
for Doctor Who making her the first ever
female producer at the BBC Lambert was
in charge of the first two series of
Doctor Who and left a project in 1965
but her legacy lives on after her start
on Doctor Who
Verity started her own television
company and worked on several shows over
the ensuing decades upon her passing in
2007 former Doctor Who showrunner
Russell T Davies said there are a
hundred people in Cardiff working on
Doctor Who and millions of viewers in
particular many children who love the
program that Verity helped create her
story along with the saga that launched
doctor who was also chronicled in the TV
movie an adventure in space and time
each time a new actor comes into play a
new version of the doctor they get a new
sartorial look Christopher Eccleston
iteration wore a black leather jacket
while Matt Smith's doctor rocked a
bowtie and occasionally Affairs the most
famous Who costume accessory however
is undoubtedly the overlong multi
colored scarf worn by the popular fourth
doctor played by Tom Baker when putting
together this particular look for the
first time costume designer James
Aitchison went to a fabric shop bought
several schemes of yarn and handed them
off to begonia up hope the mother of a
friend he later explained so I went to
be going here and I said look start
knitting he returned in a week's time to
find that Pope had knitted a scarf that
was 22 feet long but had misunderstood
the assignment and thought HSN wanted
her to not just use a little of every
color but use up every last bit of yarn
HSN added I think we shortened it a
little bit though
product placement isn't a modern day
phenomenon in fact shows in consumer
goods companies have been working
together for decades
case in point forth dr. Tom Baker's
stint as a salesman for prime computers
in the 1980s Baker starting a
hilariously cheesy series of commercials
Hawking the computer brand in which he
had to use prime computers to save the
world the company was moderately popular
in the 1980s and peaked sometime around
1988
unfortunately the company went defunct
during the following decade but luckily
the commercials still exist because good
want to miss this
unlike other TV science-fiction
stalwarts dr. who has never expanded its
universe with a big screen movie - who
related films were released in the 1960s
but they are extremely different from
the TV series to say the least
seeking to capitalize on the merchandise
spawning popularity of Doctor Who's most
recognizable villains the Daleks amicus
productions bought the movie rights to
three Dalek based Doctor Who adventures
from the BBC and their creator who wrote
a Terry nation Doctor Who and the Daleks
and Daleks invasion earth 2150 AD are
not an extension of the main Doctor Who
Canon in the films the doctor isn't a
Time Lord from another planet who
travels around in the TARDIS the rather
a human doctor whose last name is who
played
horror legend to pay to Cushing bursting
full-color when the television dr. hood
was still airing in black and white the
first film was a hit but the second one
bond leading amicus to cancel plans for
a third Dalek movie
oh well thanks to the concept of free
generation plenty of different actors
have taken up the doctor's mantle and
some potential stars could have taken
the franchise in very different
directions according to The Times
Michael Jackson and Bill Cosby were at
the top of the list to play the doctor
in a 1988 film adaption that never
materialized these might seem like some
out the box choices for the role but
remember this was the late 1980s Jackson
was trying to branch into film with
efforts like Captain EO and moon Walker
while Cosby was in the midst of The
Cosby Show success fans waited years for
a female or black take on the iconic
character but it's amazing to think the
show could have embraced that diversity
far earlier then it ultimately did
though he softened his stance on Doctor
Who as of late Christopher Eccleston
famously disliked the show following his
one-year stint as the doctor when it
relaunched in 2005 after a 16 year break
the actor told The Daily Record he'd had
enough with the show and once he
realized he and the showrunners were
never going to compromise over the
creative direction of the series he
decided to leave leading to the first
regeneration of the modern era
despite his quick exit Eccleston still
deserves a lot of credit for
successfully relaunching the show the
actor was actually invited back to the
50th anniversary special but
negotiations broke down before a deal
could be made Eccleston's role was
eventually reworked to introduce John
Hertz war doctor introduced in the 2007
episode blink the terrifying weeping
angels are essentially statues only ones
that can move the terrifying speeds so
long as nobody's looking at them created
by writer Steven Moffat these unsettling
creatures are actually based on a
real-life experience while on vacation
in the coastal English county of Dorset
Moffat walked past the graveyard and
decided to have a look around inside he
found a statue of a weeping angel but
here's where it gets weird years later
Moffat returned to the graveyard but the
angel was nowhere to be seen
Moffat explained to the Oxford Union
there are two possible explanations one
is that the weeping angels are real
the other is that I somehow made up the
weeping angel and it was never there he
even did some research into the
graveyard and found no evidence that
there was ever a weeping angel statue
there it's crazy to think but doctor who
has actually been around long enough
that kids who watched the series growing
up and now old enough to actually be
writing and producing the series and
that's exactly what happened for extra
runner Steven Moffat in 1995 when he was
still just a fan Moffat posited a fan
theory in a Doctor Who chatroom his idea
was that the universe developed the word
doctor to describe a healer or pigs'
maker based on the legend of the doctors
travels throughout time and space Moffat
admitted his theory was stupid but said
he was rather proud of it anyway fast
forward 16 years and Moffat is running
Doctor Who in the 2011 episode a good
man goes to war
Alex Kingston's River Song gives a
speech to the doctor that pretty much
turns Moffett's fair theory into canon
doctor the word for healer and wise man
throughout the universe we kept that
word from you you know
much the same way showrunner Steven
Moffat relished the chance to make his
fan theory Kalen Doctor Who star Peter
Capaldi was also living out a childhood
dream during his time on the show
Capaldi was a hardcore Doctor Who fan as
a teenager and has made no secret about
the fact that the show is what inspired
him to get into show business rather
famously Capaldi was so obsessed with
Doctor Who that he constantly bombarded
the show's creative team with fan mail
to the point that one of them once
openly wished the Daleks would
exterminate him Keith Miller who ran the
Doctor Who fan club at the time wrote in
his book he haunted my time running the
fan club
he was quite indignant he wasn't
considered for the post and the shards
production Secretary Sarah Newman
couldn't stand him after the departure
of Peter Capaldi in 2017 Jodie Whittaker
made history becoming not only the
thirteenth actor to portray the doctor
in an official capacity but also the
first woman the regeneration coincided
with a switch in backstage talent to as
longtime showrunner Steven Moffat
left the series in the hands of Chris
Chibnall for jib no costing a woman in
the role was never a question of should
but one of her according to the baby
safe ship Knoll selected Whitaker after
months of lists conversations auditions
and recalls but he always knew that his
doctor would be a woman but the road to
Whitaker was a long one in 1986 BBC head
of drama Sydney Newman told producers
that the next doctor ought to be a
female while fret comm stars Dawn French
and Joanna Lumley were briefly
considered human suggestion was
overruled in the end service the McCoy
became doctor number 7 Oscar winner Dame
Judi Dench was later considered to star
in the show's mid-2000s reboot
ultimately losing out to Christopher
Eccleston check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]